nougat justement qualissons et Berlingo
se retrouveront peut-être aussi sur vos
tables de Noël après une période
critique le conservatoire de la
confiserie à Amboise retrouve son élan
de nouveaux investisseurs ont accepté de
prêter main forte à la jeune entreprise
qui va donc pouvoir continuer à faire
rêver les gourmands vous voyez ce
reportage de Sarah gros
la passion de Nicolas violet et
désormais sauvée le conservatoire de la
confiserie d'Amboise René de ses cendres
depuis fin octobre c'est un soulagement
pour son fondateur et ses salariés je
suis très contente que on ait des
nouveaux projets qui sont en cours qui
vont aller sur le long terme qu'on
puisse pouvoir s'amuser un petit peu
encore et pouvoir faire vivre encore
notre passion pouvoir continuer de la
transmettre un sauvetage rendu possible
grâce à deux sociétés locales pour
éponger une dette de 14000 euros Terre
Exotique Emma innovation entre au
capital de la confiserie pour le gérant
de la deuxième entreprise son soutien
raisonné comme une évidence on connaît
Nicolas violet depuis très longtemps il
venaient nous acheter des moules quand
il avait encore 13 14 ans avec son père
c'était quelqu'un de déjà de passionné
et qui quand il venait nous voir avec
ses projets avait déjà les yeux qui
pétillaient et qui ont été passionnés le
travail s'effectuer désormais en équipe
les deux nouveaux partenaires
apporteront leur expertise en gestion et
commerce une nouvelle aventure
prometteuse pour le futur de la
confiserie il y avait un potentiel
énorme et qu'en fin de compte vu le peu
de moyens que j'avais et le peu de
soutien que j'avais mais je pouvais pas
faire face à tout ça donc eux ils ont
apporté toute cette logistique cette
communication donc il y a plein de
choses qui se mettent en place grâce à
eux on se retrouve avec deux partenaires
vraiment solides et avec lequel on
complémentaires en fin de compte donc
c'est ça ce qui est chouette c'est que
on peut pas mieux rêver un rêve d'enfant
de nouveau possible Nicolas violet et se
permet agrandir ses locaux pour
accueillir les nombreux visiteurs dans
de meilleures conditions c'est donc
serein qu'il peut envisager l'avenir
alors gardez vos dents elles n'auront
qu'à bien se tenir